[Musique]
mais oui mais oui l'école est finie les
enfants sont à la maison penchés sur
leurs devoirs et dans la cour leur est
au grand ménage demain l'école LAURENT
vergess DU PORT s'ouvrira sans la
moindre trace de la veille et de Laurent
vergess que rest
ce est-ce que vous savez qui était
Laurent Verget non pas exactement je
sais que c'est le frère de Paul VI
garçon de Paul céit un bon garçon
c'était un ami d'enfance un homme
politique anci il était député un des
plus jeunes députés que la Réunion et
même je crois que la France a eu il est
Mor à la route la corn il a eu un
accident et non il oubliera
pas fils de Paul vergess et de Laurence
deouin Laurent est né à Saint-Denis en
avril
1955 peut-être marqué par l'arrestation
sous ses yeux de son père quand il
n'avait que 9 ans il arrête vite ses
études d'économie pour se lancer dans la
vie active le bâtiment tout d'abord et
puis le journalisme pendant 5 ans il
travaille à Paris à l'humanité préoccupé
par les problèmes du tiers monde il part
au Sahara occidental et dans différents
pays d'Amérique latine de là il écrit
aussi des articles pour témoignage en
1979 il couvre le voyage à la Réunion de
George marchetis alors leader du PCF un
an plus tard il rentre définitivement au
pays et prend la tête de témoignage
qu'il souhaite transformer en journal
antionformiste corrosif et subversif
mais l'action politique prend rapidement
le dessus en février 1983 il est élu
conseiller régional sur la liste du PCR
en mars la mairie de Saint-André lui
échappe de quelques voix seulement en
1987 à la démission de son père de
l'Assemblée nationale il prend son siège
ce que nous disons à cet électorat c'est
que l'égalité est inséparable du
développement en juin 1988 il est élu
député de la 2è circonscription avec 56
% des voix dès le premier tour mais le
tout jeune député ne siègera pas
longtemps le 7 octobre il est victime
d'un grave accident de voiture sur la
route du littoral 20h c'est l'accident à
la hauteur de la pointe du goufre les
raisons de l'accident inconnu jusqu'à
présent mais il est évident que c'est un
homme fatigé qui il sucom à ses
blessures 5 jours plus tard il n'avait
que 33 ans les
[Musique]
gabillion